situé au coeur du continent africain le
tchad est le plus vaste et le plus
peuplé des états de l'ancienne afrique
équatoriale déhima s'il peut forme en
transition entre les étendues
désertiques du sahara au nord est de la
savane soudanaise au sud le tchad ne
possède aucune façade maritime et se
trouve séparé de la mère par de vastes
territoires difficultés d'accès donc eux
qui en conservant au tchad de son
originalité nous ont donné le privilège
peu enviable de compter parmi les pays
les plus chers du monde
la tonne de ciment vos cinquante mille
anciens francs à fort lamy et cela se
comprend si l'on pense que les
marchandises débarquées à douala
allez go soit point thouars ont parcouru
des milliers de kilomètres par la route
ou par le fleuve avant d'arriver à
destination
géographiquement et arbitrairement le
pays peut se diviser en 3 grandes zones
au centre la zone sahélienne qui vient
mourir au bord du lac tchad au nord la
zone saharienne coupé par les massifs du
tibesti et de l'aîné dit au sud enfin la
zone de savane paradis des animaux et
des chasseurs
ces contrastes géographiques et la
position du tchad au carrefour de
l'afrique blanche et de l'afrique noire
explique la grande diversité qui existe
tant sur le plan ethnique et
linguistique que sur le plan religieux
au nord vivent les arabes et les foules
pays islamisés éleveurs nomades de peu
et de chameaux au sud par contre on rend
compte de nombreuses races négroïde
animiste catholiques ou protestants dont
les traditions sont pourtant restée
vivace encore que les [__] à
plateau est pratiquement disparu du
moins le diamètre des plateaux at il
diminué
c'est là dans le sud que d'yves lessard
un excellent agriculteurs et valeureux
combattants dont beaucoup ont servi dans
les rangs de l'armée française
enfin sur les bords du fleuve on
rencontre les kotoko le célèbre pour
leur danse et leur pêche miraculeuse
c'est que le poisson tient une grande
importance dans l'économie tchadien les
rives du chari et du logone constitue
une des zones piscicole les plus riches
du monde et chaque année les kotoko et
les bananas pêche cent mille tonnes de
poissons frais qui fumaient ou séchés
seront exportés vers la nigeria ou le
cameroun c'est dans les eaux du logone
qu'on pêche aux grandes et mitel et le
nom de ses filets et qu'on pêche le sa
langue à sorte de harengs d'eau douce ou
le capitaine justement renommée pour la
finesse de sa chair poisson qui avec le
sorgho et mobiles constituent la base de
l'alimentation des populations
tchadiennes
voilà donc ce pays ce peuple aux
origines diverses fractionné en
multiples groupes ethniques qui parle
des dialectes différents et qui est
pourtant unis par une longue tradition
de vie commune dans le cadre d'un ancien
support devenu un état indépendant
fortement centralisé sous la conduite de
son chef monsieur françois tombalbaye
mais justement les structures
traditionnelles ne sont elles pas les
plus fortes
l'antagonisme entre le nord et le sud at
il disparu
le chat at il fait sa révolution comment
le pays est passé du régime quasi
féodale imposé par les sultans à un
régime démocratique de type occidental
voilà les questions que j'ai posées à
fort-lamy à monsieur tombalbaye
sur le plan politique comme tout le
monde le fait il s'est toujours posé de
problèmes politiques à l'intérieur dé ce
qu'on appelait autrefois le territoire
français parce que la présence de
multiples leaders politiques tchadiens
c'est l'époque était à l'origine de
sites luttes tribales
je crois pour ma part que la chefferie
où le sultan dans son ensemble week end
à son existence qu'elle représente
inna structures traditionnelles et qu'il
ne fallait pas sous une forme ou sous un
prétexte de d'une nouvelle orientation
les supprimer brutalement
ceci étant dit j'ai suis arrivé à
montaut à intégrer également les chefs
et les sultans dans l'ensemble de non
pas dans le parti progressiste humaine
dans l'ensemble des lubrifiants contre
pied du tchad
ces sultans les voici riche ou pauvre
potentats régnant sur des régions
entières
ou bien droite les deux villages tous
ont conservé le décor fragile de leur
souveraineté garde personnelle serviteur
courtisans musiciens sans oublier les
femmes du harem dont le nombre est
fonction de la richesse de leur seigneur
et maître
mais ce n'est là qu'un écho en fait
depuis l'abolition de l'esclavagé
les sultans sont devenus les auxiliaires
de l'administration
certains allant jusqu'à demander au
corps électoral
la ratification de leur autorité devenus
députés ou conseillers municipaux les
sultans ont ainsi permis au tchad de
passer sans trop de secousses du
moyen-âge au 20e siècle mais au xxème
siècle il faut produire sous peine de
perry l'économie du tchad se ramène
essentiellement à deux grandes activités
la culture du coton dans le sud et
l'élevage dans le nord l'élevage de ces
quatre millions de boeufs et cinq
millions de moutons c'est aussi trois
cent mille berger pour la plupart
nomades une grande partie de la viande
est exportée sur pied vers le nigeria et
le soudan mais depuis la construction
des abattoirs frigorifiques de phares
chain dans la banlieue de fort-lamy un
tonnage important est exportée par avion
dans toute l'afrique et au sahara
bon an mal an les produits de l'élevage
représente pour les éleveurs tchadiens
en revenus de plus de 2 milliards
d'anciens l'autre richesse du chat c'est
le coton traités sur place à fort
archambault
introduit au tchad dès 1929 et couvrant
maintenant 290 1000 hectares c'est la
seule culture vraiment industrielle de
ce pays le coton graine est débarrassé
de ses impuretés et transformé en fibres
emballé par balles de 200 kg ce le
photon du tchad est exporté dans le
monde entier production annuelle 98
mille tonnes de graines qui donne 35
mille tonnes de fibres fort-lamy la
capitale du tchad n'était en 1920 qu'un
petit village c'est aujourd'hui une
grande cité de 100000 habitants qui
s'étale paresseusement sur les bords du
chat malgré quelques immeubles modernes
qui abrite l'administration et le
gouvernement
la ville a su préserver son caractère
africain à la fois familial est bonne en
mai pour nous français fort lamy ce
n'est pas seulement la capitale du tchad
c'est aussi un haut lieu de l'histoire
les départs d'une épopée dont les
tchadiens conserve le souvenir avec un
soin jaloux éboué leclerc de nom gravé
sur la pierre et dans les mémoires de
noms que l'on retrouve partout à fort
lamy avec les noms des victoires de la
france libre
non le tchad avec la dépendance n'a pas
renoncé à son amitié pour la serrure en
témoigne éloquemment et monsieur
françois tombalbaye le proclame avec
force
il est évident que il n'y a rien qui
oppose le tchad à la france comme il n'y
a rien qui doit inquiéter la france à
l'égard du tchad le cadre des tempes et
quand même à travers l'afrique
d'expression française qu'à plus de
danser combattants c'est le pays où il
ya eu beaucoup de souvenirs de bière
étant donné qu'elle marque le tchad dans
l'histoire dernière était la première à
répondre au général de gorge et je
souhaite que cette visite symbolique
donc la fraternité entre les anciens
combattants de nos deux pays
au nom de cette amitié et de cette
fraternité bienvenue en france monsieur
le président